thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle and bees everywhere in the
air
he's denouncing bees objection ah the
non-low here makes an objection
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we are covering the
highly requested b-movie an animated
movie about bees that sue humanity for
stealing their honey I think this is the
movie I was born to review be sure to
comment in the form of an objection
which I will either sustain or overrule
and stick around until the end of this
video where I will give the bee movie a
grade for legal realism so without
further ado let's dig in to the B movie
[Music]
our top story a tri-county bee Barry
Benson is saying he intends to sue the
human race for stealing our honey
packaging it and profiting from it
illegally alright so right out of the
gate big problem with Barry's lawsuit
you cannot sue the entire human race to
sue a party in court they have to be a
recognizable entity that can be sued an
individual a corporation who would show
up who would hire the attorneys who
would be the material witnesses in this
case all of those are reasons why the
human race is not a party that has
standing to be sued in court but it's
similar to when people have tried to sue
God in federal and state court every few
years you get one of these jokers who
thinks it would be cute to name God as a
party and every time it is rejected
sometimes the courts just dismissed the
case out of hand because there's no way
to properly notify God because God
doesn't have a fixed address to accept
service of the lawsuit and other times
they will let the lawsuit go forward and
let the case go into what's called
default which means that the propounding
party wins because the other party
didn't respond but the problem is
there's no way to recover whatever
winnings you might be entitled to from
God so it's a Pyrrhic victory in either
case why please actual work going on
here
is that that same bee yes it is I'm
helping him sue the human race Wow
okay so not only can an individual not
sue the entire human race because that
lawsuit would fail a florist cannot help
you sue another party in court that is
called the unauthorized practice of law
so she can actually get herself into
trouble for practicing law when she
doesn't have a law license maybe this
could make up for it a little bit you
know very this lawsuits a pretty big
deal I guess are you sure that you want
to go through is it am I sure what I'm
done with the humans they won't be able
to say honey I'm home without paying a
royalty okay well one of the reasons you
hire an attorney is so that you can file
your complaint that starts the lawsuit
in a way that the court will accept you
cannot mail in your complaint to most
courts you have to actually go down to
the courthouse file the complaint itself
and serve that complaint on other people
hear what Vanessa has done is she's just
put a document into the mail mailed it
to the court and nothing is going to
happen they will probably just throw
that out because that's not the proper
way to start a lawsuit in New York also
if we can rewind it we can see that
she's also addressed the complaint to
the wrong place
she has addressed her complaint to the
Superior Court of New York now while the
Superior Court is the correct court in
California the trial court in New York
is actually called the Supreme Court I
think the writers for the b-movie
probably work in Los Angeles or
California where you call the trial
court the Superior Court that's not the
case in New York so there are many many
reasons why this complaint would be
rejected by the court in New York all
right case number four 475 Superior
Court of New York Barry B Benson versus
the honey industry is now in session
mr. Montgomery you're representing the
five major food companies collectively a
privilege okay so this is interesting
they actually rolled back the lawsuit
when they got to court itself instead of
suing humanity they are only suing five
farmers who happen to keep bees
happened to harvest and sell the honey
this lawsuit also doesn't work but for
slightly different reasons mr. Benson
you're representing all bees of the
world I'm kidding I'm kidding
yes your honor we're ready to proceed
all right so what Barry Benson is trying
to do here is what's called a
class-action lawsuit where a few
representative plaintiffs claim that
they are representative of a larger
class of people and as a result they
claim that they should be able to
prosecute the lawsuit on behalf of all
of those people who are similarly
affected so would Barry Benson be able
to proceed further with a class-action
lawsuit well let's think like a lawyer
going with the federal definition there
are some requirements you have to meet
before you're able to proceed further
with a class-action lawsuit in a federal
system this is governed by rule 23 of
the Federal Rules of Civil Procedure
which requires you to have one an
adequate class definition two that the
Class B ascertainable three that there
must be numerosity in other words a lot
of people four there must be commonality
amongst all of the class members five
there must be typicality between the
representative plaintiffs and the class
members six you have to have adequacy of
counsel and seven you have to meet some
other requirements to show that
class-action status is warranted here
all of those requirements are not met
number one there is a terrible class
definition they've defined the class as
all B's well some B's haven't had their
honey taken some B's have had their
honey taken in different ways so the
class definition is necessarily
problematic number two the class has to
be ascertainable there are billions if
not trillions of bees out there and
there is no way to identify the
individually effected bees three
numerosity there's a lot of bees out
there that probably would be met but
number four is that there must be
commonality amongst all of the class
members and because different bees are
treated differently
there's not enough commonality amongst
the class to move forward number five
there is no reason to assume that Barry
Benson is typical of all of the other
class members number six adequacy of
counsel is definitely not there Barry's
not even a lawyer so he can't even
proceed with this proceeding let alone
adequately represent the actual class
members that he's trying to move forward
with and for the same reasons all of the
other requirements of rule 23 are not
met as well so basically this class
action is absolutely doomed to fail and
it would not move forward in any way
whatsoever and mr. Montgomery your
opening statement please
opening statement you don't go straight
from the first hearing and filing a
complaint right into trial that's
totally ridiculous there would be years
of pretrial discovery and motion
practice before you even got to trial
little own trial happening on the first
day ladies and gentlemen of the jury my
grandmother was a simple woman why is
there a jury in this case that also
doesn't make sense
and I've mentioned this a million times
before you don't get to go straight from
counsel table walk right into the well
of the court and then go straight at the
jury judges and juries really hate it
when you invade the personal space of
the jury
and if you were aggressive about it the
bailiff will tackle you how do we know
this isn't some sort of holographic
motion picture capture hollywood
wizardry they could be using robotics
ventriloquism cloning for all we know he
could be on steroids
that is completely improper argument and
would be stricken from the record mr.
Benson
again he's not a lawyer he doesn't get
to give an opening statement
ladies and gentlemen of the jury there's
no trickery here I'm just an ordinary
bee and again you don't get to fly
straight from counsel table directly to
the ledge in front of the jury and then
give your opening statement you're
invading the personal space of the jury
and both the jury and the judge are not
going to allow that and as a bee honey's
pretty important to me it's important to
all bees we invented it we make it and
we protect it with our lives
unfortunately there are some people in
this room who think they can take
whatever they want from us because we're
the little guys and what I'm hoping is
that after this is all over you'll see
how by taking our honey you're not only
taking away everything we have but
everything we are okay so so bees are
what we refer to in the legal world as
chattel almost all animals are it means
that they are animate objects that are
owned by some other human and it is
fully within the right of the owner of
the chattel to get the fruits of those
particular animals whether it's milk
from cows or whether it's eggs from
chicken or honey from bees if you own
those animals generally you are entitled
to what they produce but if bees somehow
were able to prove that they were
conscious and fully sentient then they
might have a conceivable argument that
taking honey from them is a form of
conversion or theft to which they would
be entitled to some compensation animal
rights activists have tried to give
rights to lots of different animals in
different contexts for example the the
famous selfie picture that was taken by
a particular monkey but until that time
animals do not have the same rights as
humans they cannot file a lawsuit they
cannot defend themselves in court and
they do not have property rights so
mister Klaus van der Heyden of honey
farms pretty big company you have there
I suppose so and I see you also own
honey Burt and hon Ron yes the
propellants for our farms
beekeeper I find that to be a very
disturbing term I have to say I don't
imagine you employ any bee Freer's do
you
no I'm sorry objection argumentative oh
no because you don't freebies you keep
bees objection argumentative
it seems you thought a bear would be an
appropriate image for a jar of honey
well they're very lovable objection
relevance
why is this relevancy bear Oh build a
bear kill bees
all right so in addition to being
completely irrelevant to the court
proceedings I probably don't need to
tell you that when you bring a
demonstrative into court this is a
demonstrative something that you bring
into court for demonstration of some
particular idea it cannot be a lethal
animal it cannot be really probably any
animal at all unless it was like a
service dog this is completely improper
if this would be thrown out immediately
and probably a mistrial declared well I
just think it was awfully nice of that
bear to pitch in like that I'm telling
you I think the jury's on her side are
we doing everything right you know
legally I'm a florist exactly she's a
florist why is she sitting at counsel
table
why is she helping with this lawsuit
that is the unauthorized practice of law
you know I just about had it with your
little mind games what's that
Italian phone man that's a lot of pages
it's a lot of ads remember what Vance
said why is your life any more valuable
than mine that's funny I just can't seem
to recall that
I think something so we learned earlier
in the movie that bees cannot be struck
by paper of more than 30 pages in a
world where bees are sentient and
conscious
I think it's hacking a bee with a
magazine of that size is probably
attempted murder so you know tell that
to all your kids I guess what exactly is
your relationship to that woman
relevance character good friends yes how
good people and bees should be making
objections right now we give birth to
all the B children in the haves yeah no
those aren't even your real parents
Oh Barry yes they are a proper character
relevance dancing bees and don't y'all
date your cousins objection I'm gonna
pin good huh
the non-law hair makes an objection
Adam dog that's what he wants
then that'd be just commit suicide
important to note that one of the
reasons we have a legal system in the
first place is so that we don't have to
rely on violence to solve our problems
and the B's here are supposed to be the
good guys they're trying to get just
outcome from their lawsuit and yet the
Beco counsel here has given in to his
aggression and he has attacked the
opposing party the opposing attorney
with his venomous stinger that's not
something that you would want an officer
of the court to do and if in fact he was
a real lawyer he'd probably get
disbarred for that and assuming you've
done step 29 correctly you're ready for
the tub yeah you don't get to talk to
the jury like that without the presence
of the judge mr. flamen yes yes yes your
honor where is uh well well Your Honor
it's it's interesting you know bees are
trained to fly kind of haphazardly and
as a result when often we don't make
very good time so I should point out if
you are not in court when the judge
tells you to be in court you're in a
world of hurt judges hate it when
lawyers don't show up on time they can
issue sanctions and in the worst case
they can dismiss your case for not
showing up on time you know and Unferth
inspection that co-counsel bee has
attacked the opposing counsel there is
absolutely no way that he would be
allowed to sit at counsel table anymore
number one he would be arrested
number two the judge would probably have
to declare a mistrial because of the
outburst that occurred it's not fair to
either party to have to proceed with a
tainted jury as a result of the lawyers
bad conduct in assaulting each other
they have presented no compelling
evidence to support their charges
against my clients all run perfectly
legitimate businesses I move for
completes entire case so this happens a
lot in movies where the opposing side
will say that the other side has
presented no evidence whatsoever and the
case should be thrown out and usually
when they say that it's at the beginning
of the case when there wouldn't actually
be any evidence here the plaintiff bees
have had ample opportunity to
demonstrate the validity of their case
by presenting evidence and they simply
haven't they've engaged in a bunch of
sin Anakin's
they have not presented any relevant
evidence and as a result the opposing
side here is making a motion to dismiss
the case that is actually something you
can do in a real court case you can move
for what's called a directed verdict or
AJ Nov it basically just means that the
plaintiff hasn't met their burden and
there's no reason in proceeding into the
defendants case because the plaintiff
hasn't met their evidentiary burden in
the first place so this is the first
accurate thing that this movie has done
this is the time to make a motion for a
directed verdict where's your proof
where's the evidence
show me the smoking gun you want a
smoking gun here is your smoking gun
what is that it's a bee smoker
what is this harmless little contraption
so this is somewhat relevant evidence
you would use the smoke gun to
demonstrate that the bees haven't
consented to having their honey taken
away from them which is one of the
elements you have to show for theft or
conversion that being said there are so
many other hurdles here that this would
be just a tiny bit of relevant evidence
it really doesn't get to the end of the
court case but still at least it's
relevant evidence for once ladies and
gentlemen please free these bees yeah
that's something happens in movies all
the time it does not happen in real life
at all the judge cannot decide in the
middle of the court case to just grant
the verdict in favor of the plaintiffs
this would be overturned on appeal
immediately because the defendants have
been denied their due process
congratulations on your victory what are
you going to demand as a settlement
first we're gonna demand a complete
shutdown of all bee work Kanner's yeah
that would not happen then we want to
get back all the honey that was ours to
begin with every last drop so when you
win a lawsuit generally you are entitled
to monetary compensation you can
sometimes get back the actual physical
things that you feel you are entitled to
that is a legal concept called specific
performance you are getting the
defendants to give you the specific
thing that you think you're entitled to
generally that happens in real estate
cases because real estate is always
unique but if it's possible to give
financial compensation the court almost
always will give financial compensation
and there's no reason that the bees
couldn't be given financial compensation
instead of a return of all of the honey
on top of that all of the things that
they are getting in this potential
settlement would never be given by the
court it's completely unreal
stick and would never happen we demand
an end to the glorification of the bear
as anything more than a filthy smelly
big-headed bad-breath stink machine I
believe we're all aware of what they do
in the woods wait for my signal
take them out yeah if you're entitled to
compensation for your honey you don't
then get to assault other people for
some weird reason why the bees hate the
Bears that's a whole separate issue I
guess and we will no longer tolerate
derogatory be negative nicknames
prance-about stage name and that's a
First Amendment violation health
products and la-dee-da human tea time
snack garnishments and there's no reason
why an injunction would be granted to
prevent people from using the honey
that's already in the stream of Commerce
okay so that's the bee movie but how
realistic is it well it's time to give
the bee movie a grade for legal realism
the b-movie effectively gets everything
wrong about lawsuits bees and florists
cannot be lawyers the process by which
the court proceeded in this case is
completely wrong and would be grounds
for appeal everything that happened that
case is completely unrealistic about the
only thing they got right was that the
opposing attorney made a motion for a
directed verdict at about the right time
so I give the b-movie a solid B for
legal realism actually I'm just kidding
it gets an F it's terrible it's the most
unrealistic thing I've ever seen in my
life
but you know kids movie so what are you
gonna do if you don't move he won't
sting you freeze the B movie teaches us
that it's okay to be curious about your
world it also teaches us that it's hard
out there for a B even though bees can't
sue humanity they are facing a crisis of
extinction after watching the B movie I
pulled up a great documentary about bees
on curiosity stream called more than
honey it talks about this worldwide bee
phenomenon why bees are in danger and
what we can do about it I'm just saying
all life has value you don't know what
he's capable of feeling real bees are
not as cute as the B movie but they
still play a vital role in our ecosystem
if you're as curious about the world as
berry B Benson you should check out
curiosity stream legal eagles will get a
free account on curiosity stream for 31
days by clicking on the link below or
using the promo code legal eagle using
the promo code really helps out this
channel so click on the link below and
check out the greatest documentaries on
the planet so do you agree leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other lawyerly reactions over here in
this playlist where I will see you in
court